bonsoir à ses côtés
et nous cherchons
[Musique]
messieurs dames bienvenue dans la vidéo
spéciale halloween il ya quelques jours
on a eu un très d'horreur spécial cinq
histoires l'occasion du lancement des
pré commandes de la bd blick aujourd'hui
c'est la vidéo halloween et cette année
on a voulu faire un truc spécial nous
sommes avec mehdi marzouki du bruit
mais personne n'y a pas c'est pour
montrer qui a personne à personne mais
dit miley est légèrement stressée pour
se poser à moi que ça fait deux heures
qu'on attend de tournée on a spéculé sur
ce qui nous attend on est en bas ne sait
rien en fait on sait rien pour de vrai
bon vous allez tout comprendre je vous
explique ce qui va se passer au jour
tout nouveau concept et 10 as tu déjà
joué à des jeux d'horreur jamais aucun
jeu dommage un bus à haute classe non
fahrenheit après dix noms resident evil
commun présenté binôme sur ce qu'on a vu
aujourd'hui c'est littéralement un jeu
d'horreur mais dans la vraie vie
incroyable je sais juste qu'il va y
avoir des énigmes des personnages qui
vont nous faire baver probablement
sûrement des objectifs à accomplir le
tout pour aller au bout du jeu j'appelle
ça le jeu car tout comme toi je ne sais
pas ce qui nous attend aujourd'hui il
n'y aura pas de cadres heures c'est nous
la forêt on est tout seul c'est après un
tournage je vais tout seul avec sa aussi
avec mon meilleur pote ça fait quoi
maintenant qu'on se connaît maintenant
trois jours vous allez donc suivre les
aventures à vivre via les go pro qu'on a
sur nous je pense qu'il y aura des
caméras autour de nous qu'on verra pas
forcément d'ailleurs ah oui aussi en
équipement on a notre téléphone on n'a
que ça ce téléphone va nous servir pour
nous éclairer avec le flash prendre des
notes et prendre des photos et des
vidéos et le but c'est d'aller au bout
de ce jeu mais touche au taf et ce
jusqu'à bienne wen a gagné les escaliers
chute libre et que
je suis pas trop moi les gars je vous le
dis je suis excité comme une puce mais
vraiment franchement pour halloween sec
ça me fait trop peu sur glace maman et
j'envoie le bisou en l'absence je fais
ça vous savez que ces attentions déjà un
synopsis de ce jeu legrand jd nous
fameux la légende a besoin d'être nous
nous rendons sur les lieux pour voler à
son secours
[Rires]
donc là tu as mis les pieds là le jeu et
commence ça y est c'est parti moi je
cherche pour un rondin de bois pour des
freins mais
c'est terrible
sait jamais quand je mets mon flash on
voit vraiment rien je deviens parano
parce que comme on en voit des skates
bienne j'ai trouvé un 2.5 c'est dans le
shanxi
je croyais comme ça si une grosse
araignée groupe paul a claqué un jour
une lumière bon on est d'accord que
c'est déjà très stressant ah oui c'est
bien ça va les mecs
j'ai eu peur
bien bien calme vous savez pourquoi vous
êtes là non pourquoi vous avez déjà
entendu parler de l'histoire de la
famille bridard non en fait c'est une
musique qui fait beaucoup parler d'elle
en ce moment sur internet il ya pas mal
d'abonnés qui m'ont dit vas-y va faire
un truc là bas tu vois et c'est une
maison qu'il y a des trucs étranges le
truc bizarre les trucs un talent je
regarde parfois non mais t'as raison
parce qu'il ya des trucs très étrange
qui se passe dans cette maison on parle
de disparition de personnes des choses
comme ça tu vois on sait pas exactement
c'est pour ça que lucas mais dit vous
allez rentrer dans cette maison et le
but c'est donc été de savoir ce qui se
passe et pour ça vous avez justement des
téléphones vous allez prendre des photos
essayer de prendre un maximum d'infos tu
m'écoutes
chartres
donc voilà ça c'est l'info de base ok
moi je serai avec vous tout au long de
cette enquête donc si vous avez des
conseils c'est pas exactement qui si
vous êtes perdus etc vous pouvez me
poser des question de parler hockey
hockey parce que j'ai réussi à placer
deux trois caméras dans la maison et je
me suis fait un petit qg hockey ce soir
vous avez rendez vous avec sylvain brida
c'est le fils de la famille qui habite
us là bas
vous ai réservé deux chambres et vous
allez passer la nuit à l'intérieur ok on
est au milieu de nulle part donc c'est
très important de quitter ce lieu avec
un véhicule gm blessures
à partir de maintenant je vais aller
mettre en place dès que je vous dis go
dans l'oreillette vous allez frapper à
la porte et c'est senna qui nous
accueille dans un bol
bon c'est pas
beaucoup
encouragé très angoissant mais tout ça
on voit ça et je n'ai jamais vu comme ça
l'uqam eddy ferhi dévouement très sympa
un deux trois temps retourner c'est bon
c'est vous qui peut paraître très belle
très belle voix et il fait plus peur que
la maison est ce que vous êtes prêts
ouais je crois qu'on est prêt vous
pourrez les frapper à la porte de la
maison et dire bonjour à ses toiles et
des mortiers merci mec c'est parti mais
caméras sont en place à eux de jouer taj
arrive pas pour qu'on agit d un
supporter meilleur support possible
mexes et resident evil 2 où c'est la dhr
bah ouais je perçois
pour y est
par des
attentats prennent le faire briller par
ses stocks avant le 8 octobre oui on
politiques ont dit combien on a deux
choix jdg têtu pourtant bien sûr je suis
autant ludique on a deux chambres
réservées c'est ce point nommé
n'inquiète pas airbnb vous avez loué des
chambres aucun souci ça va bien se
passer ces deux jours
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir on a deux jours vous
êtes cinéma ouais si je meurs en
championnat et lui car sylvain médian
chanter chanter bon bah bienvenus merci
beaucoup sont alors que je vous explique
un petit peu voilà c'est une maison qui
a construit mon grand-père en 1925 donc
voir c'est une maison habitée à l'année
donc il ya tout un inconfort voilà vous
avez évidemment wifi le code est près de
la boxe c'est un petit peu vous voyez un
peu cabane au fond des bois quoi ma mère
est un peu passionné de taxidermie donc
à voile à 2,3 à nîmes employait voilà et
puis sinon bah écoutez cuisine toute
équipée 1 il ya tout la vaisselle frigo
mon il doit pas rester grand chose un
les derniers locataires ont dû laisser
deux trois bricoles mais bon on va faire
un marché demain sans
problème
juste pour vous dire moi je vis dans
l'indépendance qui est juste en dessous
là qu'ils allumaient hockey s'il ya le
moindre souci vous n'hésitez pas ok
gloire que vous dire d'autre c'est une
maison ancienne donc de temps en temps
il ya des petites pannes d'électricité
savent pas souvent mais c'est arrivé une
ou deux fois donc dans ces cas là pas
d'inquiétude les plans sont à la cave je
serai avoir les clés donc vous n'hésitez
pas à vous venez me voir de la même
manière voilà on va monter alors oui si
alors j'ai un petit soucis je suis
désolé on a eu un petit prince de
toiture voiture ouais et donc on a eu un
petit dégât des eaux dans une des
chambres ok ok donc la chambre de gauche
est condamné pour l'instant j'en suis
désolé donc il nous reste plus qu'une
chambre on a essayé de faire au mieux
une seule chambre il ya un grand lit
dans la chambre on livre andy roddick au
pire de ou snacks en face à dax non
je suis désolé quoi et ça arrive bon
allez on va monter vous en prie après
après vous embrasser la cave c'est ça en
bas où c'est la cave mais bon on stocke
des trucs hockey à attendait excusez moi
bon j'ai une petite urgence parce que je
vais faire c'est que je vais vous
laisser explorer là haut vous n'hésitez
pas si allemand de souci je vous laisse
vous installer à huy et les clés sont la
laisser les clés sont là on n'a pas les
clefs de la cadence assez vous annoncer
les clés bois pour rentrer et sortir
très bien merci et au revoir
[Musique]
[Rires]
à partir de maintenant regardez autour
de vous s'il trouvait un maximum
d'indicés fait attention quand même mais
c'est partir mais que moi j'étais bloqué
sur les animaux en paille j'ai envoyé
par jd ouais on est dans la chambre
s'est jamais vois ça va aller atrocement
flip back moi je danse dans le cas d'un
ami fidèle et prudent vaut le meilleur
départ en vrac on est là pour comprendre
que les disparitions et où il ya
forcément un truc avec salah un lecteur
cd mais qu il ya un cd un scud c koi
colplay comme ben non c'est ça
les mecs où il attendait vérifier déjà
que si j'en ai bien parti est retourné
au salon
[Musique]
y'avait châkidor web
il ya concentrez vous dépêcher les
immenses finalement mais sylvain je veux
pas qu'ils reviennent mais il était allé
dans sa cabane au fond du jardin kawnik
à temps il ya les clés de la maison on a
tous on est enfermé et à tort il nous a
enfermés derrière c'est rocheuses faire
ça mais quand ça lui faisait enfermer
ya qu une seule porte non il ya une
tension ne partirons pas
on est enfermé dans la maison cela il va
falloir trouver les vraies clés pour
ouvrir les portes ok ou est-ce qu'on est
des clés vas-y
grosse à mme ashton le fait qu'ils ne
nous enfermons ça fait des jeux en bois
mais c'est fou
sylvain dit la glace sympa comme ça mais
c'est le pire cela sylvain brunet s'ils
vont faire lundi juste au dessus de toi
c'est quoi cette photo la belle fille de
filles mais attends je n'ai vu là ça
rien de prévu la veille à un mec en plus
mais qu'elle a aussi mec maintenant je
sais pas si c'est par sa de
barack mec de moi là j'ai une petite
fleur de peau de culte du corps je pense
la veille sur nous c'est la maison d'un
autre mais
un gros ça fait flipper de fou et
attendez attendez quelqu'un jouer du
piano c'est quoi jouer du piano il ya un
truc sur le canon j'ai mal je suis
à toi c sont l on dirait il ya un code
est un code pour trouver le monde a
retrouvé le matin j'ai cru
[Musique]
les caps se téléphone ça m'intéresse
qu'est ce qui se passe quand vous le
touchez et ça demande un code et c4 il
faut quatre chiffres là il ya un quart
des notes ya peut-être des notes dans ce
truc c'est quoi ça c'est du hockey je
sais pas ok jd on est en train de
fouiller en tient au courant si on
trouve un truc mais 10 derrière toi
regarde les coussins qui sont space non
caisse quoi vas-y vas-y tchac tchac
tchac t il arrive maintenant elle est
morte
continuez continuez continuez quand tu
veux redire tout carrément le
oui ok
ok qu'est ce que c'est que cette
enveloppe ok ok ok c'est nadine couvrir
ces êtres des mères tu as vu s'agit des
montres mois à la caméra ça doit être un
corridor un truc comme ça d'après une
photo ouais la kbc décédé bz sécu dr
c'est un truc qu'on peut déchiffrer de
noyau et bien semer genre pour une table
parce que je pense qu'il ya une logique
à capter en fait je pense aussi cette z
mm abc est ce qu'un jour tu remplaces
j'ai pas des consonnes ou des voyelles
les cdc forcément le lin yue exactement
ok j'ai cdc le cdr c'est les lps donc le
fcs donc fait une démo c'est cnn quoi
fini de plus tard 6 et 2 e notre buteur
benzema
attend ya un style schéma sursis noir
sylvain bidart bien sûr l'arrestation je
pensais que c'était genre ça des
lunettes après
oui c'est à raison c'est sain pour la d1
c'est ça et ça ça aide vous êtes bon
t'as raison casse humaine dans un ace
dans 20 des démons qu après qu oui oui
c'est ça sa carte dont elles ont décliné
il ya ces biens et à continuer
dans un des quatre photos de mes parents
se trouvent de quoi comprendre mon
portable tous d'anciens nous
ok ça se passe tout dans le salon et il
faut absolument déverrouiller ce
portable à temps mais de mes parents
chaque indice qu'on trouve nous amène
vers l' indice d'après l'enveloppent
nous amène vers les cadres les cadres
vont nous amener vers le prochain truc
photo ap en coiffe énormément ignoble
dis comme je le pense bush of stock de
ce raid horaire ça alors
non ça c'est moi
6 et non il dit glen il faut tous
familles non au banana voilà trois ya un
truc est ce que c'est ça mais dit non on
a une grille et ça commence par 3 ou sa
fille pour 3 ou c'est une échelle en
haut à droite bien ça très bien vous
avez bien checker l'enveloppent du début
on applique
ses caves et le téléphone regarde ça
c'est le de clavier du téléphone
est bon reprenez le portable et fait un
bilan de ce que vous avez nous le
portons ce qu'ils voient et des
mouvements l'attend mais il ya peut-être
attendait
bien joué on a tous on a tous on attend
clairement faut aller sur le code ce que
ça peut être soit ça soit ça soit ça
soit 100
la raison tout est là oui le premier
chiffre soit 4 soit sus voilà et le
deuxième c'est soit 1 soit 9 exactement
6 7 2
c'est pas ça vraiment vraiment fait
guère de ne pas bloquer le portable en
mode je pense que vous n'avez pas ouais
ensuite ça peut être quatre sets 1 2 non
mais qu'on va le blocage est toujours
sans contrat et on n'a plus droit
d'avoir on n'a plus droit à l'erreur ok
jd on a essayé le dernier le premier et
c'est le deuxième ou troisième langue
s'ils voulaient même pas là
6 7 9 2 j'espère qu'il s'agit
bien de vidéos ian griffin vidéo je me
plais directement besoin
qu'est ce qui se passe c'est une vidéo
il ay qui pioche dans une sorte de camp
fleurs de plantes où il ya plein de
fruits rouges il cache un truc genre
confie camoufler un truc moi comme si 80
des photos donc ça c'est de
l'acharnement
c'est ça la hâte en ouais c'est la
surface laissant on soulève
c'est vrai tu es un mec dirait des
petits piments frérot il ya un truc là
rien oui bien phu et bien pas vraiment
là dans la vidéo montre ça ça doit être
là dedans ou sept enfants m'ont fait
beaucoup de monde mais c'est bien c'est
ton petit côté jardini qui ressort à
l'amour faire tout part absolument pas
non attends je l'aide parce que moi j'ai
la main verte j'ai trois
jeunes et c'est une clé mais je l'aimé
waouh ok j'étais là depuis le thunder
est en moi je suis toujours pour laisser
aucune trace répond avec sylvain
ironiques l'un la caution morale c'est
la clé or c'est une chute de 4 c'est pas
pour sortir ce que ce n'est pas une
terreur contre un mec noémie c'est la
chambre de la petite 100%
jours vas-y vas-y mik
la juin bruxelles juste le chat
c'est pour fait je vous promets ça sert
à coeur mois
l'élection d'une vue sa
noirot au kenya il ya plein de le kenya
il ya des radios il ya des petits
chiffres sur des post-it je couve
toujours nos arrières métier il faut
fermer la porte mais prend la clé pour
que la collecte
je dors
hockey regarde c'est on dirait des
victimes seules les cinq articles
portant le nom de charles moderne
intéresse ok il ya des numéros avec cinq
photos à mon avis et couteaux sont
importantes se trouvaient cinq l'article
pourtant non charles baudelaire à 20 par
la danse bordel les articles on cherche
on tient au courant on cherche on
cherche
ah ouais le corps d'une petite fille a
été substitué à celui des
leaders blick
je peux encore faim dans la mer un gang
vous avez le temps on est au top on est
au top ok vas-y il faut qu'on rassemble
tout ce journal ouais c'est l'uci ouais
tout ce qui ressemble à ça rires la
human à rien ça non c'est pas le même
public sur le bureau il ya des trucs
là regarde grieder blick y en a encore
la regardera la raideur blick rider
blick ggg et enfin 5 il en manque deux
contre deux
on fait tout amusé son père lui que
c'est cool
ça me fait bizarre de tomber sur le
journal qu'il ya dans blick quoi
j'en ai
vraiment c'est très bien c'est arrivé
c'est par un
à devant vous sur le mur il me semble
sans aide
oh mais coup merci gêné grâce à
votre téléphone face aux flashs merci
free tout le temps qu'ils invoquaient le
flash comme ça un grave défi on a les
seins qu'on a les seins qui donc à
charles joder dans ces cinq trucs là
ouais charles gilbert cauchemars aux
maisons d'hôtes charles baudelaire
rimbaud des responsables d'un odieux
moeurs et odoi à toi il ya le numéro des
trucs pendant un an nettement 6 7 5 5
bien qu'au-delà qui devrait être capable
moi je foute la paix à 0
jd peux tu peux m'aider notre un code
pourquoi en compte l' âme et attend il y
avait un truc à elle c'est exactement ça
et ça se trouve c'est là dedans attends
je vais trouver à temps sous l'île
doit y avoir un truc au vieux os à
offrir ah oui j'ai pas check et cela
à ces mecs j'ai trouvé
c'est un code à cinq chiffres la
monarchie c'est ça c'est les 5 qu'on a
c'est les 5 contre parents non je pense
que l'ordre le plus important c'est
celui qui a affiché devant vous auquel
il faut mettre en rapport ça et ça
exactement avec les enfants les
d'articles en fait un réseau une femme à
cheveux longs taches de rousseur c'est
la 5 c'est la 5e des gerrard fait la 4
un enfant a disparu sans laisser de
traces donc ça c'est l'art un ouais
c'est bien ça nous donne en question et
achetés dans son épais bien mais qu'un
celui-ci donc savamment vertes ont elles
aussi un bel avenir
c'est tout con c'est soit ça soit ça
j'ai bien joué et bien joué 6 est clair
moi
si cinq
sets
c'est bon bien joué j'ai fait bravo
qu'est ce qui est à l'intérieur alors un
de juive on a incarné un jd avec
marc et journal intime top secret je
vois ça ouais à 1,25 rhône où on va tous
comprendre par couple vous en boivent
d'une manière mais je ne sais pas
forcément très gentil c'est c'est par
ici on me fait beaucoup de peine cher
journal je vais te dire tous les secret
et surtout mes pensées les plus
profondes
ça se trouve c'est est un proche de la
famille sylvain là qu'on voit donc
continuer mes parents que j'adore ok on
avait compris ça m'a dit mais 10 mai 10
mai mais excusez moi c'est ta caméra qui
fait
excuse moi vraiment
j'ai cru que c'était un truc bizarre oui
mais j'ai envie de m'asseoir du vient
s'asseoir sur le banc
non mais il fait peur mais qu continuez
vous êtes bien continuer dessiné tous
les jours pour devenir illustratrice
et non rigole ou suggérer que tu veux
j'en ai lu m'a dit qu'il a entendu des
rumeurs chelou sur ma maison à skip les
anciens locataires auraient disparu du
jour au lendemain à vous le proprio et
rochelle où je le vois très notre de la
maison c'est vraiment creepy d'abord
c'est sylvain facilement les portes de
la maison
la dépendance la barre mes parents
passent de plus en plus de temps avec
l'autre bridard je sais pas pourquoi
mais ses potes et lui ils ont l'air
chelou il me met grave malaise à la fin
de l'hyper intéressant viennent pas chez
moi il ya deux pages qui manquent ouais
ok mais c'est quoi le texte a écrit
sylvain a toujours intel qui vaut le
coup d'envoi dépendance je sais pas avec
qui communiquer dessus trop bizarre
j'essaierai de le récupérer à l'occasion
pour en savoir avec un mec est dans la
cave il discutait avec un mec est dans
la came tout est déchiré oh mon dieu
quelqu'un vient de fermer ma chambre à
clé et a pris mon téléphone continue
c'est très bien c'est un cauchemar je
les entends ils ont emmené par dans la
cave j'ai peur je ne veux pas mourir moi
mais alors nation géante en plus mes
parents il faut que j'aille les aider et
les clés de la carte ne peuvent être que
dans la dépendance de han han van bree
dans la dépense
c'était quoi sans aucune idée mais tu
veux tu vois rien aucun nom c'est un peu
coupé affirme adam championnat
un choix
roj
bon ben on va dormir là tous les deux
c'est good segaunes pour pour la taille
c'est pas grave bref si tu rentres moi
je vais dormir en danger aucun souci
avec lui cette culture
tout me fait peur c'est y aller j'y
allais foyers dans la gamme enfin on n'a
pas le choix
mais là il y avait quelqu'un à deux
secondes c'est ce qu'il faisait je pense
un filtre de leur dépendance et de
choper lesquels est exactement l
apartheid où
il ya des problèmes de connexion je suis
vraiment désolé
allé discrètement dans la dépendance
je rappelle qu'à la base
je suis quelqu'un sans voiture est ce
parce qu'un 6 4
ok nous
il ya des champs partout
avec les
générations fais gaffe les trois
passes et la défense c'est une auberge
c'est une île où il vivait un quatrième
d'une famille et les trousses hippisme
par les fermes bien la porte ouais
toujours
les gars c'est la première fois qu'on a
accès à cette pièce est vraiment une
aubaine il va falloir fouiller et
trouver des informations
donc là on cherche et qui est de la cave
ok c'est une vitrine pige à nantes s'est
dit prêt à renier horrible même si c'est
pas des briques en fait j'ai vu des
chats tout à l'heure j'ai une phobie des
chats à mais qui a du sang sur l'appel
mais bon c'est pas du saint
lô c'est tout qui avec lequel il parle à
son côté al hakam exactement il me
semble aussi on n'essaie pas de
contacter son patin n'ont pas su
agrémenter un fait attention et les voir
un homme
se serait trop simple de juste trouver
des créneaux ba ouai mais on va se taper
ning des ceintures et 3 son
dressing il n'y a aucune hygiène de vie
il n'a pas eu d'éducation quoi
tchèque souligne ce n'est pas ce que je
vais dire tu pleures tu as trouvé à
temps où tu cacheras une clé rien
chapeau dans le chapeau sous le chapeau
mais et l araignée j'ai pas envie
de vous confondre avec son fils dit ah
ouais ouais je m'envole et mais attend
ses duels avec la chanteuse non
d'avoir une boîte ya une bonne base
écrivez-moi le contenu offre lui c'est
lui frère celui sein du groupe a séduit
oh non on va voir un artiste frère frère
qu'est ce qui se passe
chez nous à vertex et wat mais oui je
sais même pas d'où je sais les mecs vous
pouvez me décrire ces des photos de nous
remémorer ces prochaines saisons
incroyables gauche une photo avant que
j'ai vu une telle musique ce que j'ai
moi
tu passes devant des gradins photo c'est
une cata
retour de retour
de la
[Rires]
paix dans la file
d'attenté des spectacles et bien et bien
en place il a dissous le totem danger la
vie j'ai trop regarder koh lanta il me
semble bien qu'il a dit ça paraît dans
toutes les manches et paris fc qui est
le thème autour de vous non mais ça doit
s est peut-être dans la maison bio totem
attendez attendez quoi il y ait du
mouvement
[Musique]
je crois qu'il va est revenu
bien
quelques jours par la photo mec
égide est ce parce qu
il va falloir vous sortiez tout
doucement on va se cacher dans hard way
sortez et allez dans le jardin mais on
va pas les crises pas grave tout autant
rester là restait là
à les yaris
sortez il faut sortir
ça
ah ça pique
on cherche les clean sous un totem
il va nous voir depuis la maison
ça totem ça c'est ça le totem exactement
à ces sousse et sundhoffen attend ya une
pelle faut peut-être causé aux fiches
surveille ce que
cela donnera non
c'est bon c'est mon objectif parfait les
mecs
la mise en eau libre ou quoi non non
attendez
un jardin d'un jardin
on cherche
[Musique]
entrez dans la dépendance qu'il faut les
avec vous avez la terrible ouais mon
jouet se faire découper ok pour fuir toi
de maison elle est trop
c'est incroyable ça déjà ils sont
confiés
c'est très bien fait qu'elle accapare
perd pas de temps c'est à ce moment là
on est gris dit il va nous chercher
c'est là parce qu'on est tous dans la
cuisine à voir
[Musique]
american psycho s'adonnèrent je vois pas
très bien
[Musique]
encore salim rouille regarde regarde mon
coeur de mausolées mec wallace et bien
rentrer
il ya des de 39 ans déjà c'est
un truc satanique tous cas c'est
complètement ça c'est qu'un le rituel
des radis rva été créée en l'an mille
huit cents par la première est liée
débris d'art une famille qui entretient
des rites anciens de sacrifices cd sorti
une secte sherry tu es là lui au milieu
de la nuit fit jour avoir un nouvelle
lune pour fois ils vont nous vendre des
personnes à sacrifier et d'une centaine
et là ça va être plus clair saison mais
qui n'a pas mal d'infos c'est bon la
tasse qui font pourtant délicate parce
qu'à ses débuts il ya un ordinateur et
un ordinateur pas c'est fini les pa
cotation terrain gibert
bon c'est toi pauvre con qui connaissent
tout ça ok regarde bien je vais à l
ordinateur
il salue observons toujours lecture en
fait ni en bon goût truffaut audio et
les tueurs en série sous windows xp ce
fut vrai qu'est-ce qui assurent leur dit
il ya une session de charles joder la
session est ouverte ailleurs ne pas
stocker votre réunion passera autour de
venir en ami ok alors chers l'on gère
l'eau de roche bois j'espère que tu veux
bien qu'on me convient je ne sais que
d'autres passages pensait pas ça les
gars il va falloir
on a parlé tout est bas dans ce n'était
pas ton
la tête ça non
annonce a montré une page et je suis
j'ai perdu à cause de
ça
[Musique]
ok tu vois gilet orange va exactement
fait ce que je n'ai pas eu le temps de
faire photographier les dossiers des
membres dans l'ordinateur dans
l'enveloppent le mémo de charles
vaudaire je ne peux pas le traduire en
question valent mata côté qu'on aura
réussi à filmer vos pages 21 un lieu
incertain pages de l'image des lignes
des mots ouais et s'est donné une lettre
à chaque fois est un lieu incertain
c'est le nom du livre je suppose mais
bon j'avais un livre qui s'appelle comme
ça un lieu un certain fred vargas on l'a
on là ok
je fais partie 21 21 ouais ligne 7 mo
six auxquelles est trop honte h 20 15 h
ont à dire 71 win32 mot trois lettres un
as
tu veux le faire un peu on s'échange nos
jeunes debout
mais ce n'est très des ports page 94
ligne 13 mo 4 la carte ils croient
qu'ils adorent ça bouge
il fait plus peur que ces images et des
mots une vente de la cité des 62 8 mo de
l'être cette can am et à l'état
c'était pas un hommage le troc été
[Musique]
oublié par des photographies s'apprendre
des preuves là il ya un truc membres
éminents et lui cherche faut dire oui
ces mutants qui m'aimait les c'est que
des membres du haut conseil il ya arnaud
laurent poirier gabriela vaudaire charme
quant à vis de maximilien et il ya
thomas rené
complet
il
dépêchez vous attend il a dit ne savons
rien c'est la bagnole et les clés qui
sont dans son cabanon pour ceux cassés
je reviens construire
il vient dans la maison en fait rien ça
s'agite chance
que j avais
entendu où étaient les clés de la
voiture ces incidents sont bonnes je
vais vous donner un ami il a fallu
retourner dans la dépendance camargue
[Musique]
banny
non
des bons coups
il faut habituellement son amabilité
n'est pas thomas genevois mais c'est bon
charmant
je parle souvent
il appartient d'abord
en visite ce qu'on
attend et on a tout bien globalement on
va prendre une voiture en ce cas
il faut vraiment qu'on se casse parce
que là ils ont commencé le tromper dit à
la clé notamment gelac les faits une
fille actrice avait des téléphones avec
vous avez des preuves on a tous on a dû
souffrir
on l'est tous les cas la voiture elle
est posée sur le côté tu passes par la
maison elle bouge suis pas sa terrasse
et il ya un petit chemin vers la gauche
je crois quand même la pause de midi moi
je retrouve ce chapeau non c'est
dégueulasse on allait pouvoir sortir ses
petits sur tout doucement
allez-y
pourquoi
[Applaudissements]
evans ivan court
thibault
l'ipad
bon sang
la voiture la voiture
on partira pas
partez partez partez
dégager de cette maison
t'as déjà conduit
séoul est morte hier
m
ce casque à ciel
galvan jan van eyck les gars c'est beau
pour vous ouais enfin bon c'est vous je
crois que c'est bon bien joué on a gagné
je dis si bien joué tfou bougez pas je
vous rejoins
c'est fou mec comme en ce moment ça
s'accélère ouais mec moi il ya un moment
les gars ou jeu j'étais plus la gta
autre genre merde on va mourir
lui avait dit
oh le croyant bravo voilà
python nous être fou tellement j'étais
parti je n'ai pas réussi à démarrer au
début je suis je perdais mes moyens dans
le stress et je les voyais arriver un
fait mais moi je démarre pas on a posé
une question d'orgueil m'a dit qu'on t'a
déjà couru une fiat une conduite
différente une tactique on a vécu trop
de scènes de films
richard a notamment les chats mec moi
j'ai buggé sur janot se dit pourquoi il
ya pourquoi il ya autant de chats légal
est ce que vous allez kiffer un mec
c'était un choix je m'attendais à un
truc chaud je pensais que ce serait
limite un peu plus évident en mode on va
avoir peur des venir nous faire
peur un peu plus trapu en très
exactement là c'était beaucoup plus
section entre guillemets et genre
vachement mercier ne sait pas trop à
quoi je l'aï mercialys et moi le feu le
silva il m'a mis dans un mode mec
j'appuierai contre lui mais je veux pas
le voir et j'espère du cauchemar de lui
je vous dis mais j'étais tellement dans
l'ain genre vraiment
ça s'accélère en fait quand on rendra un
champ de noémie salah c'est là en fait
où tu dis ouais c'est le bordel moi
c'est là où franchement on avait perdu
les gars devenez fou je voulais prendre
des couteaux et
des bruits qui menaient des escaliers y
avait vraiment un mec dans les escaliers
et tu l'as vu
ma table est-ce qu'on peut applaudir
c'est sur cette vidéo danuri bravo tout
le monde on voit pas forcément évident
mais ça implique énormément de gens et
franchement mais aviv un coin mais que
c'était dingue il y avait des petites
références à blick et j'ai
particulièrement aimé ça va lancer les
précommandes une bd over et agents joe
qui s'appelle blick et donc il ya eu des
références qu'elle est là dedans voulait
précommander vous bien sûr mais tu t'es
bourrin
ouais je crois mais vous êtes vivant
c'est le plus beau halloween de ma vie
aussi mr le seul
ça va aller les moufles pour les amis
c'est la fin de cette vidéo j'espère que
ça vous a plu merci encore à vous d pour
une participation de granges des médinas
et ssii n'hésitez pas à passer voir leur
travail ces deux personnes qui font du
contenu que j'affectionne
particulièrement ce sont ces régions si
chaque année - l'insee ça je suis au
fait je vous dis tout de suite ces
quelques données avant de revenir quand
même tu pars avec la fiat et tu reviens
l'année prochaine
[Applaudissements]
merci à vous d'avoir regardé la vidéo
joyeux halloween ciao
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
incroyable les photos et sort d'où ces
photos nous c'est pas une photo que j'ai
intégré moi c'était sur ton âge des
traits d'âge était de force qu'avec des
sous mais nous on se connait pas
vus compact à toi tu as des traîtres au
courant